I'm Johnny Mendez former CIA officer and
a founding board member of the
International Spy Museum I'm here to
answer some questions from Twitter this
is spy support
[Music]
at spicy lime415 asks do spies have
anxiety I think all spies have anxiety
you want to make sure you're not setting
someone up for a situation because you
forgot a detail when the anxiety really
kicks in though is when one of your
people is incarcerated is arrested in
Moscow I felt anxiety all the time
Moscow I thought was kind of scary in
1985 10 of our Russian assets were
arrested and executed 10 of them in the
summer that kind of anxiety is built
into the job there's nothing you can do
about it except when you're working make
sure that you absolutely respect the
protocols that we have to go through and
level of detail that's required to carry
off an operation at Rosemary Chalet one
asks what are CIA handlers what you're
calling CIA handlers I'm calling CIA
case officers they get the requirement
from the government we want to know
about nuclear program in this country a
they go to Country a they go looking for
people who know the information about
country a once they meet them they try
and recruit them to work for us and then
we get the information back to our
policy makers cut and dry at imk
Johnston has anyone seen the movie Argo
just about to watch it the story in the
movie Argo is really a great
demonstration of the kinds of things
that that CIA may find itself involved
in a rescue of six perfectly innocent
American diplomats didn't have anything
to do with espionage except that The
Rescuer happened to be a spy my husband
Tony Mendez they used Hollywood as a
cover in that instance the cover
organization in LA to cover the
operation if anybody called that office
and said do these people work there the
answer would be yes six people being
rescued were schooled in their cover
stories over a period of three days
issued every piece of paper with their
new name on it and they were whisked out
of a very very dangerous situation Ben
Affleck pretending to be my husband that
was interesting at s Holton rvt asks did
you know there's a CIA position titled
chief of Disguise how freaking cool is
that person I was chief of Disguise for
two years I was Deputy Chief of Disguise
before that chief of Disguise has a
worldwide staff we always have in the
back of our minds this memo that the
person The Foreigner is going to take
back to his office and say oh I met with
this American and everything in in his
description of the American that he met
is going to be wrong from the hair color
length is it curly or not color of eyes
it's going to be wrong does he wear
glasses it's going to be wrong does he
smoke is he married does he have a gold
chain around his neck all of that is
wrong it's a disguise and it keeps our
officer safe at pybry Pro asks CIA MI6
and KGB FSB how do they develop soft
skills like situational awareness social
engineering blending in and creating
believable cover stories what combat
training do they receive CIA had a
paramilitary capability and decided to
more or less step away from it after 9
11 CIA stepped back up to paramilitary
and has embraced it I know they do train
and some of the harder skills in
shooting in driving and being in a
hostile situations we have a facility
where we train people it's called The
Farm a lot of people have heard of it
the farm is located south of Washington
in D.C they actually put on diplomatic
events at the farm and you are an
attendee all dressed up and there's
someone in that room who has information
that you're looking for and part of the
training is to see if you can narrow it
down to that person by just having
conversations at Sigma Theory asks what
makes a good spy what we're recruiting
for when we're looking for spies and
we're talking about case officers here
is a charismatic intelligent
well-educated well-traveled guy mostly
but it's more and more women someone
you'd meet somewhere and you'd instantly
want to be the friend there are people
like this around the world our job is to
find them because we cannot teach them
that we can teach them everything else
they need to know once we get them on
board but that Charisma they have to
bring it in the door with them at Mary
Marciniak asks no signs of me being
followed me am I being followed seeing
someone who looks suspicious once is not
such a big deal if you see that person
again that's interesting that's a
coincidence but the third time starting
to approach confirmation that that
person is sticking with you for whatever
reason there are lots of ways around it
we would go into a place and go out
another door we would go into a place
and come out like different we would go
into a place and someone looking just
like us would come out next question you
know the whole spy thing is cyanide and
a fake tooth where they bite down and
poison themselves how often do you think
those go off accidentally like someone
is just enjoying a nice hard candy and
then oops dead in my 27 years I only
knew of two instances where we gave out
Cyanide and I knew where they were
because the steel box containing it was
in my safe the Russians floated stories
around that if they caught their people
spying for America they would feed them
feet first into a crematorium alive most
people in Russia that spied for us had
that in the back of their minds and they
thought they'd rather take the cyanide
themselves than take the chance that the
Russians meant that and would do it
it was very effective we didn't hand it
out like it was candy it wasn't candy it
was Lethal and I do know that cyanide
really really works at Ginny X asks does
anyone know of a good small spy camera I
was a photographer when I first joined
the CIA that was my gig
and this camera was part of my account
this pin camera the camera in the end
inside of the camera is a film cassette
and inside of the cassette is a little
piece of film it's about 13 inches long
it have a hundred black dots on it after
you develop it and each black dot would
be an eight and a half by eleven page of
information where the paperwork is lying
from his last meeting we only gave these
pins to people that could get right up
to the person who was making the policy
we were after you had to hold it at a
certain distance you can take the
picture this is a KGB lighter they were
actually technically very very good so I
can't disparage it but if it was a CIA
lighter it would actually light at
underscore Rhys asked do spies get paid
a lot of money like people who spy on
other countries and the answer at
underscore Reese is no they don't pass
enough they pay us flat government
salaries just like anybody else you work
at GSA you work at IRS wherever you work
in the government we're on the same pay
scale as them now the assets that are
working for us the foreigners who are
providing us with the intelligence that
we need depending on the value of the
intelligence they can make big amounts
of money there's a man in this Museum
Adolf talkachev it's called the billion
dollar spy because of the intelligence
that he gave to the Pentagon while we
didn't pay him a billion dollars the
Pentagon said his intelligence was worth
a billion dollars Adolf talkachev made a
lot of money except that he got caught
and then they executed him so I don't
think he had time to spend it at taku
underscore zero underscore zero he says
it's crazy how the CIA has three levels
of Disguise like it sounds fun to go to
level three to like your high school
reunion I basically break disguise down
into two levels you have regular
disguise and you have advanced disguise
regular disguise is what you think it is
it's mustaches and wigs and all the
accoutrement that you can put on to
change the way you look Advanced
disguise takes it way up to another
level where you're talking about wearing
masks we would actually like prostheses
this is a sample of a mold of a nose
we're going to change a nose on a face
using one of these we could change your
teeth if we thought it would make a big
difference we can change almost anything
at will
fight for you how many CIA assets and
spec ops units do you think the U.S has
on the ground in Ukraine right now my
answer would be
uninformed but a pretty confident
many
at aaronjack24 says I want to see one of
these five second mass in real life it
was a breakthrough once we could make
those masks we could do a lot of new
things that we'd never been able to
before we could make your face and put
it on someone else we have one here in
the museum it's a mass that I wore in
the White House to brief the president
of the United States is very effective
the design goal was put it on in a car
without a mirror in the dark you'd know
okay that's it it's on Pat the hair down
get out of the car and if you ran into
trouble you could literally pull it off
in three seconds crumple it down put it
under your arm and walk down the street
at head funny asks real life spies are
never attractive are they it would be
detrimental to the job our model of the
little gray man which is a model we
actually used all the time the idea was
we wanted you to be so unnoticeable that
people wouldn't even remember if you had
gotten on and off of their elevator we
we don't want you to attract attention
the CIA doesn't use seduction as a tool
I have to say on the other hand
that the Russians do and they have in
the past the East Germans used male
swallows they used good-looking men to
go into West Germany and recruit the
secretaries of the heads of state they
did that successfully at CIA it's
actually a firing offense if you sleep
with your foreign asset at Jane
Gallagher asks what did microdots used
to do micro dots were a way of
communicating with a foreign agent a
very very secure way of doing it they
may well be doing it today it looks old
school but the security trumps
everything else a microdot is a page a
normal page of text eight and a half by
eleven reduced down 400 times and what
you get at the end of that reduction
is a DOT a tiny black spot
there are two of them on the back of
this stamp he'd pull his little tiny
lens out of wherever he had it stored
looked like a grain of rice he'd put it
in the hole in the card get some spit
pick up the dot put it on the end of the
thing
and hold it up to a light and he could
read an eight and a half by eleven page
text it was a very very secure way of
communicating with an Asian at Jerry
rasanen asks aren't all diplomats spies
by definition all diplomats jiri in
answer to your question are not
necessarily spies but some spies can be
considered to be diplomats for cover
purposes diplomatic privileges keep you
safe they keep you out of trouble they
get you out of a country When Things
Fall Apart you are somewhat untouchable
when you have diplomatic cover that's a
very useful thing to have state
department doesn't like our using
diplomatic cover because for every one
of us using their cover they have one
less actual Diplomat there's a tension
there at lawn C Zhu learn when to abort
a mission in a book that Tony Mendez and
I wrote called the Moscow rules one of
the Moscow rules is to listen to your
gut always if you're on your way to do
anything and it doesn't feel right abort
the mission and at CIA overseas in the
station the chief of station always
knows there's no shame in coming back
and saying I can't even explain it it
didn't feel right I aborted the mission
we'll reschedule we'll do it again it
was one of our rules at Steven to the
mask asks I'm very interested in whether
or not American spies do have real
families and real friends or is
everything in their lives a lie you have
a choice to make when you are undercover
at CIA whether to tell your family or
not I think most people do tell their
family because it's hard to do a lot of
what we do without without a supportive
family it's your friends that have
become the issue most of us almost all
of us have to live our cover with our
friends and this creates attention over
time that different people treat
different ways but a lot of people that
I know at CIA slowly let go of those
outside friendships and we replace them
with inside friendships people who know
where you work and then they know you
can't really talk about it either but
they understand admit Dyson asks
watching killing Eve makes me wonder how
do spies pay for stuff are they issued
credit cards for their fake identities
do they just carry suspicious amounts of
cash we do not carry suspicious amounts
of cash if we can help it if one of our
CIA officers undercover was picked up
overseas and his billfold was
confiscated
everything in that billfold would
probably be fake from a driver's license
to a credit card and it would be in his
cover name not in his true name if it's
on paper or plastic we can make it
officially for government use in the CIA
we can and we do at Drew T Mitch asks do
spies get acting lessons do Yale School
of drama professors adjunct at the CIA
we don't get acting lessons so at CIA
when we give somebody a disguise for the
first time do you like it they always
say oh it's great I love it yeah it
feels good and then we say good go to
lunch in the cafeteria where everybody
you know is having lunch in the
cafeteria you wear it to the cafeteria
then come back and see us and they walk
out the door kind of sheepish and they
come back usually just amazed they
walked right by their boss he didn't
know he sat next to the guys he works
with they didn't know he was then we
think okay we did good now he'll wear it
if he needs it with the disguise you
come up with a character that you are
when you are in that disguise complete
with the call clothing that you wear the
shoes that you wear do you smoke all of
this you invent a character that doesn't
exist and you become that character when
you're wearing the disguise at I am
Sergio Grant asks how do spies get
recruited we run ads in a lot of media
we come to college campuses for for job
fairs and we set up tables and talk to
anybody who walks up to us knowing that
a lot of the people walk up to us really
just to see what we look like my husband
Tony Mendez initially replied to an
advertisement in a newspaper said wanted
to work overseas for the U.S Navy
because they didn't want to say in the
newspaper back then that it was CIA go
to cia.gov and you can apply online at
maximum underline Q what is a double
agent a double agent is an agent
pretending to spy for one country while
he's actually acting on behalf of
another when we bring new agents on
board at CIA there's a whole process of
validating that person that processing
and that bringing an agent on board is
all about making sure that they're not
double agents and then cia's most famous
double agent at this point I guess was
Alder James who was a CIA officer but he
was actually reporting to the Russians
over years and that's where the 10
Russians that were executed in Moscow at
85 those were names that he gave to the
Russians these are the names of your
colleagues who are reporting to the CIA
and they kill them at nacha regular I
want to learn how to do dead drops so
bad but I'm scared your goal with a dead
drop is to transmit information to an
agent that you cannot meet face to face
so if we had to transmit something
whether it was money or medicine for his
kid we would give it to him in a dead
drop dead drop is something you're going
to leave by the side of the road or buy
a telephone pole or by construction site
or wherever you two decide and he's
going to pick it up at a later date
there are a number of dead drops here on
display at the Museum everything from
aldra James's mailbox there is a dead
rat I made a dead drop once that was so
wonderful it was a Potomac River Rock
that would hold a lot of stuff the only
Dead Drop I ever knew that we gave a
name to we called It Rock Hudson at
Maddie and McKay asks do spies have to
go up a pant size to inconspicuously
store guns on their backs we don't
normally carry guns on our backs in fact
we don't normally carry guns at all but
if we did they would be small and they
would be inconspicuous at magnify K asks
in a world of drones and satellites why
use a spy balloon they are easier to
control they fly lower they're carried
by the wind they also have a lot of
built-in deniability and the images that
they take are surprisingly good they're
often better than the images taken by
our satellites the problem is that
they're so easy to shoot down the most
recent episode with the Chinese shows
that this is not the way to go if you're
traveling across U.S airspace at
kt0213 ask do spies get to choose their
own code names no they do not they
assign you a code name it's a first name
a middle name a last name it's always
all in caps when we communicate around
the world about a particular employee
particular person that's the pseudonym
for the person we're talking about it
follows you for your career so those are
all the questions we have for today
thanks for watching by support